you know i was thinking about eddie
murphy eddie murphy might be the only
comic ever
to have been that good that young
to be to be to be to have had you're
talking about he was on snl when he was
19.
and the country was talking about him
and the whole country was talking saved
the show too
i mean yeah the show and then and then
stand up
i think it was dove was talking about
this like stand-up is the only you know
very few times where you have a very
young person write an amazing novel
and i think stand-up is very similar you
don't really see people get
get their voice until they're in their
30s you're not when you're young right
it's very don't have perspective yeah
you can be funny you can be like raw
[ __ ] yeah yeah you know but but i mean
it's really hard to kind of
be a comic where people go off but
eddie murphy man he when he was 20 20.
think about that i mean stadium i went
to an arena chappelle too chappelle was
what seventeen twenty
i know i think he started fourteen he
started in eighth grade
so yeah i feel like that too i feel like
you you
you do it in your 20s i feel like you
get good at it in your 30s and then i
think if you
if you have a career and you were
fortunate enough to get past it then you
become
40 because you come yeah then you become
one of the dudes but like
eddie i agree with you brian like eddie
when he did his drunk uncle or his
grandfather oh god
he put you in a mental you're in a movie
like you're like you no longer saw eddie
you saw the drunk father
you saw the drunk father and then he's
doing it and he's 20 something years old
and his wife can't leave the house so
he's funny
and he's somebody else related with him
he's such a good actor
and then he just stopped yeah he just
stopped i think he was so rich
and he started i have a couple theories
on it one let's hear it he got
super rich and he got i think he started
smoking weed
all the time 24 7 and sometimes that can
kind of
like it kind of it kind of dulls you a
little bit it kind of kind of you
depends how you are but i think with him
in that sense
i think the combination of being high
all the time
with all the money i think i think it
was more of all the money for him yeah
and as a comic you just need
that thing that i think that's why kevin
hart's a beast because thing about he's
basically
similar career to eddie right like major
movie stars
maybe five bigger movie stars in the
world than kevin hart yeah and still
tours like a [ __ ]
yeah still does clubs he has writers but
i'm just saying still
you know especially i did from his house
you know pretty relatable you know
unless you have kids
i think he's still doing it yeah he's
kevin's always stayed hungry but i think
eddie was also afraid from what i heard
he was also afraid that his old
anti-homophobic his old homophobic stuff
and also the fact that he got kind of
caught picking up somebody who was
in drag that was stuff that he was
he was worried he was going to get
called out on and he didn't want to
i heard i heard another thing too that
it was a lot of people were just
shouting at him on stage
like he was just so famous steve martin
said that steve martin said i knew i had
to stop doing comedy when
you know he's doing his egyptian thing
with a guitar and
the the his closing thing with the good
car would come down
and whatever the stage manager messed up
the guitar didn't come down
and the crowd's dying laughing he's like
i didn't say anything i haven't done
any stand up yeah they're laughing at
this [ __ ] like
they should be upset because they paid
all this money and then they were
shouting my lines before i could get
them out he's like oh yeah stop doing
this like yeah
the ride's over or right and yeah right
a whole new house yeah i guess with
eddie they were shouting like
stuff from his movies adam while eddie
was saying but
steve are saying they were shouting his
old stuff
he was like dude this isn't what i'm
doing yeah i get out i think too what
you said too i think eddie is so eddie
has been famous for 40 years on the
level of fame
like we we think that some of these
youtube people are famous like this is
like
eddie is like tom cruise famous yeah
eddie is like there's a level of fame
and he's there in comedy
with very few you could even say above
chappelle and
like eddie murphy's [ __ ] eddie murphy
like i would say he's bigger
he's not a difference he's eddie
different stratosphere yeah eddie
murphy's like the [ __ ] michael
jackson of comics i agree
and it's like an iconic thing so
talented he's so deeply he probably is
afraid of expectations but i think
especially now i think he should just if
he loves it if he really really loved it
and wanted to do it he would be doing it
and just put that aside
he's probably just like he probably
thinks it's not enough to gain
i think you're what you just said is
he's he's worried about expectations
it's really hard to kind of like you
know he was gonna he was gonna do he
started to do it like he was booking
clubs and stuff to get back into it
because
he i guess he would throw a party like
once a month or maybe once a week and
kevin hart and all the big dogs would go
to it and kevin hart on his
uh serious show was like i'm telling you
he's the funniest guy in the room yeah
oh he can easily
do it he can easily do it they're like
so finally he was like yeah i'm going to
do it and
we're like yeah and then covet hit so it
shut it down so i don't know if he's
going to revamp it
yeah i know he was thinking about doing
because he was talking about it on
comedians and cars with coffee
yeah but that was before the pandemic so
he had a whole plan right and remember
poor damon wayne's remember he started
he's there
there was rumors that he's popping up at
clubs that at the commie store
they didn't announce that they said
special guest star so all
everybody
the whole crowd thought it was eddie
murphy they're doing right i love damon
wayne's yeah yeah and when he walked in
i was like my heart for him
was like oh yeah i remember that you
could have
the hottest 10 minutes right now and it
doesn't
matter because you're not eddie murphy
all the kids
were there and it didn't go well and i
was like oh no
and he was up in the green room
backstage and i just went up and i was
like what's up legend man
you know they were like frank
he was like eddie murphy why the [ __ ]
would eddie murphy come